So today I want to talk about uh we're
going to move to kind of the final phase
of the course, which is going to be on
dynamic Bayesian games. But I want to
start with maybe one example of a VCG
mechanism cuz I think yesterday uh that
was maybe a bit abstract and a bit hard
to follow. So let's start with uh one
final example and it's going to be a VCG
mechanism or maybe we'll call it a VCG
auction
for two items.
So a lot of the classical work that we
did so far in the course and auctions we
assumed there was just one item being
auctioned off. Then we looked at the ad
auction setting which had the special
structure where there was this ranking
between the items. Here we're just going
to have two abstract items. So I'm going
to call these maybe item A
and item B.
So what the auction needs to do is it
needs to solicit bids. Maybe I'll write
what it's going to do. It's going to
collect bids
from the bidders.
And then based upon these bids, as
usual, we have to decide two things.
We have to decide how we allocate the
goods and how much everyone pays.
So then it specifies an allocation
which in this case it says who gets item
A if someone gets it and who gets item B
if anyone gets it.
Uh and then in addition to the
allocation we have to specify a payment
by each bidder.
Now I put bids in quotes because the
kind of surprising or maybe
somewhat confusing aspect of a VCG
auction is that a bid is essentially a
report or claim about how much you value
the items.
So you think of my bid is as the
auctioneer saying tell me how much you
value everything and then the bidders
say I value it this much. And that may
seem strange but if you think about a
second price auction, that's exactly
what happens because in a second price
auction people are bidding their true
valuation. So it's as if the auctioneer
is saying tell me your valuation and
then the bidders are submitting their
valuation.
So let's
put a little more structure on this.
So let's imagine that we have two
bidders.
And it's a little complicated to specify
the whole auction because we have to
specify the allocation and payment for
any vector of bids that's submitted. So
let's just go through one example. Let's
look at some vector of bids that could
be submitted. So well, we first have to
say well what is a valuation? What do I
need to tell the auctioneer if the
auctioneer is asking me how much I value
things? Well I actually have to say
three things. I have to say how much do
I value item A if I just get item A.
How much do I value item B if I just get
item B.
And then how much do I value getting
both items together?
And depending on these items, it may not
be that the the value of the the bundle
of the two items is exactly the same as
your sum of your valuations for the two
items, right? Um if you know if it's
shoes, a left shoe and a right shoe
together are much more valuable than the
the two shoes separately. Whereas other
items that are substitutes, uh the
bundle may be
uh less uh valuable than the sum of its
parts if there's some duplication
between the two parts. Maybe uh two
apples is not twice as valuable as as
one apple. So what we're going to think
of it as a table
where my valuation is going to say if I
get item A alone, what's my value? If I
get item B alone, what's my value? And
if I get the bundle, what's my value?
So bidder one is going to make some
report
and bidder two is going to make some
report.
I've made the numbers here so it works
out. So let's suppose that the report
bidder one makes is they say if I get
only item A, I value that at five.
If I get only item B, I value it at
three.
And if I get both items, I value it at
eight.
So for bidder one, it turns out their
value of the bundle is exactly the sum
of the value of the two parts. But it
doesn't have to be that way.
Now let's look at uh bidder two.
Let's suppose bidder two says I value
item A alone at two.
I value B alone at six but I only value
the bundle at seven.
So notice for bidder two, the bundle is
not worth as much to them as the sum of
its parts. If they just got A and if
they just got B, that's different from
if they get the bundle together because
for them um these two items, you know,
maybe if this if item B is like a better
version of item A, then getting both
them together is basically just as good
as getting item B.
Okay.
So let's suppose these are the reported
valuations for the two bidders. And now
we have to specify who gets what and
what the payments are. So let's go
through this. Uh maybe we'll do
allocation over here.
So remember the rule of the VCG
mechanism is that we always allocate
things efficiently.
So that is we want to maximize the sum
of the players' utilities.
So we need to think
who should item A go to
and who should item B go to?
Any thoughts here on what would be the
efficient way of allocating things
given these reports? So remember when we
say we allocated efficiently, what we
mean is we collect the reports and we
allocate in a way that would be
efficient if these were the players'
true valuations.
So taking this as sort of the truth,
let's think about the efficient way of
allocating.
So how would
how would you do this? Yeah, the front.
Uh you could give item A to person one.
Right. That seems like a good way of
doing it. So let's see. If we give item
A to person one, they get a valuation of
five.
If we give item B to person two,
they get a valuation of six which means
the sum is 11. That sounds pretty good.
If we did the opposite, we would only
get a sum of five. And if we gave both
items to the same player, we'd either
get eight or seven but that's still less
than 11. So this is going to be the
efficient allocation. This is going to
be the allocation that maximizes the sum
of the reported utilities.
But now we have to do the payments.
And I think the payments part is a bit
trickier, right? So we have to specify
two payments,
T1 and T2.
And maybe if I'm more precise I would
say this is T1 of V1 hat V2 hat.
And this is T2 of V1 hat V2 hat.
So what the mechanism is saying is if
these are the submitted valuation
reports that the two players submit,
this is how much I'm going to ask player
one to pay. And if these are the
valuation reports that are submitted,
this is how much I'm going to ask player
two to pay. to pay. And the full
mechanism is going to have to specify a
function that says what these payments
are for any submitted reports. But
writing out that full function is a bit
complicated so we'll just do this
example.
Okay?
Now what we said in class last time is
what bidder one is supposed to pay is
the externality that they impose on the
other bidders. So we have to compute two
things. We have to say if we just cared
about the other bidders and we allocated
the items to maximize the utility of the
other bidders, how well would they do?
And then we have to subtract from that
how well the bidders actually do under
this allocation. So let's do the first
start with the first part and this is
how well the other bidders could do. So
let's say I'm bidder one.
These are the submitted valuations.
If we gave bidder two, if we just
allocated things in the best way for
bidder two, what would bidder two's
valuation be?
Well what we would do is we would give
both items to bidder two.
And if we gave both items to bidder two,
then bidder two's valuation would be
seven, right? So we're going to first
start with a seven here because this is
how well the other bidders could do
optimally if bidder one weren't here. Or
in other words, if we didn't care about
bidder one and we only tried to maximize
bidder two's payoff.
Now we want to subtract from that
how well bidder two actually does.
How well does bidder two actually do
under the given allocation? What's their
actual valuation?
Six, right? So we subtract six
and we get one.
So this is the payment that bidder one
is asked to make.
Why is it one? Well,
because they're what is the effect that
they're having on the other bidders? The
other bidder, bidder two, could have
gotten the bundle AB
but because of the presence of bidder
one, bidder two is only getting the item
B by itself.
And the difference in utility for bidder
two between the bundle
and getting only B by itself is exactly
one and that's why we get this. Okay?
Now let's do it for for bidder two.
So if I'm bidder two, we first need to
compute how well bidder one would do if
bidder two weren't here.
If bidder two weren't here, bidder one
would get everything
and their utility would be eight.
How well does bidder one actually do?
Well, bidder one actually gets item A
which gives them a utility of five.
So we get eight minus five
and we see the payoff is the payment is
three.
>> [clears throat]
>> Why does bidder two have to pay more?
Because bidder two has a bigger
externality on bigger bidder one.
Bidder one would have been able to get
everything together, A and B, but
because of the presence of bidder two,
they only get item A by itself and the
difference in utility between eight and
five is three which is uh a larger
number. And this is going to this
completes the specification of a VCG
uh for this particular profile of bids.
And the result that I didn't prove but
that I claimed yesterday is that if you
use this kind of rule in a VCG auction,
it's going to be optimal for each bidder
to report truthfully. So I should maybe
make a note on this. Uh
there's an optimal strategy
for each bidder.
And what is that strategy? Well, it's
reporting truthfully.
And you might call that vi hat
equals vi.
So, whatever my true valuation is, I
look and I say this is how much I really
value a, this is how much I really value
b, and this is how much I really value
the bundle, it's optimal for me to tell
the designer exactly uh how I really
feel and be honest about it. And I can't
benefit by misreporting my valuation to
the designer.
All right. Any uh
questions on that? Yes. Will you ever
find a situation where your
externalities are going to be less than
the kind of
valuation that you have for the good?
Like that uh payment would be negative
in that case. Good question. Uh so,
you're never going to have a case where
the payments are negative. And this
follows from the the way that we define
an externality. Um
So,
>> [clears throat]
>> yeah, we have to
be a little careful about this. So, it
is true that more broadly in economics
when we talk about externalities, some
things do have positive externalities.
There are things I can do that make
activities I can do that make other
people better off. So, I guess I should
be maybe a little careful about the
terminology of externality. So, here uh
what we mean in this context by
externality is
well, we're comparing
how well the other bidder would do if we
just cared about maximizing that
bidder's utility
to how well that bidder actually does
under this allocation.
And there's no way that the current
allocation can give more to the other
bidder than if we just maximize that
bidder's utility. So, for that reason,
this number is always going to be
non-negative, and you're right if you're
thinking of other externality context,
this is a bit more special. So, it does
turn out here that the payments will
always be non-negative. They could be
zero, uh but they would never be
negative cuz in order for them to be
negative, it would have to be that the
allocation we're choosing makes the
other bidder strictly better off than
the best allocation for that bidder, and
that can't that you know, that goes
against the definition of best. Yeah.
Seven is maximizing their utility when
everyone besides myself is is in the
game, or is it just their utility alone?
Uh good question. So, the seven here
is what we're maximizing is the
sum of everyone else's utility
and we're ignoring my own utility. So,
in this case, because there's only two
bidders, the sum of everyone else's
utility is just maximizing the other
bidder's utility. But if we had three
bidders, then we would think about how
could we allocate the goods in a way to
maximize the sum of say bidders two and
three's utility, uh ignoring the effect
of the presence of bidder one. Yeah.
Good.
Any other questions on this?
Okay.
So, now let's uh change
tacks a little bit
and we're now going to move to the final
phase of the course
which is called dynamic Bayesian games.
And I think it's kind of good at this
point to pause and see where we've where
we've come. So, we can think of the
course as organized into four parts. We
have looked at static games
and dynamic games.
And we've also looked at games of
complete information
and games of incomplete information.
And basically, so far we've filled in
three of these boxes, and now we're
going to fill in the fourth box. And for
each box in each class of games, we have
a different solution concept, different
equilibrium notion. So, let's fill this
in.
So, in the first part of the course, we
started here. This would just be like
your basic strategic form game with
complete information, and our solution
concept there was just Nash equilibrium,
right?
Next, we said, well,
we looked at extensive form games where
players make moves over time, and we
said one problem with the Nash
equilibrium is it allows players to make
non-credible threats. And we said we
wanted to refine Nash equilibrium and
impose a stronger solution concept that
rules out threats that are threats that
are not credible, and that solution
concept was called subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium.
So, that was a a stronger notion than
Nash that ruled out some Nash equilibria
that we didn't find compelling because
they involved threats that were not
credible at nodes that were not reached
in the game.
Then we step back and we said, wait a
second,
our complete information seems like a
really strong assumption. A lot of times
when people come to the game and they
start the game, they know things that
other players don't. They know things
about their preferences that other
players in the game don't. So, we
introduced uh Bayesian games,
that is games that have incomplete
information, and we introduced a
solution concept for that called Bayes
Nash equilibrium or Bayesian Nash
equilibrium.
Now, this kind of dealt with the issue
of incomplete information, but it turns
out that
Bayesian Nash equilibrium doesn't deal
with the issue of non-credible threats.
And if we want to look at dynamic games
with incomplete information, we have to
both take into account the fact that
players have incomplete information, but
we also may want to rule out equilibria
that involve non-credible threats. So,
we're going to introduce today our final
solution concept, which it's not very
creative, we basically combine the
perfect from here and the Bayes from
here, and it's just called perfect
Bayesian equilibrium.
Um
I guess maybe I'll give somewhat of a
warning about this. Uh these first three
concepts are very uh are
well agreed upon. Everyone kind of
agrees what's the right notion. Once we
get to dynamic games of incomplete
information, there's been a lot of
recent work arguing about what's the
right notion of equilibrium. So, we're
going to present a particular notion
called perfect Bayesian equilibrium, but
there's like 10 other equilibrium
notions that could fill this box that
are more exotic and involve more
constraints, and people are arguing to
this day about what's the right way to
uh to define equilibrium. So, I'll just
warn you that things are a little uh
maybe trickier or uh less clear-cut in
this case, but we'll we'll try to focus
on well-trodden ground in this class.
Okay. So, I want to first today, before
defining perfect Bayesian equilibrium, I
want to give a few examples that try to
motivate why we need a new definition,
why our existing equilibrium notions are
insufficient, and then we'll go over how
we can actually solve for perfect
Bayesian equilibrium and go over the
formal definition.
So, let's start with uh
maybe a reminder
about non-credible threats and a
weakness of Nash equilibrium with
complete information, and then we'll
build on that. So, let's go back to
maybe our classic example uh where we
had two firms.
We had firm one and we had firm two.
And we'll think of firm one as a
potential entrant
and we'll think of firm two as an
incumbent.
So, firm two's already in the market.
Firm one is deciding whether to enter
the market or not. So, they're called an
entrant, but really they're potential
entrant. They may or may not enter.
And firm one is choosing whether to
enter the market, we'll call that e, or
not enter the market, we'll call that n.
And this is the example we've we've done
before.
Firm two is the incumbent. If firm one
enters, firm two is the incumbent can
choose whether to accommodate their
entry or to fight them by starting some
price war, trying to cut prices, and
doing something that hurts both players.
So,
firm two is choosing a or f.
A for accommodate the new entrant, and f
for fight against uh the new entrant.
So, let's write this as an extensive
form game.
We have firm one is here.
They're choosing whether to maybe I'll
put n here, not enter or enter.
And then if they do enter,
we have firm two,
and they're choosing to either
accommodate the entrant
or fight. Let me make sure I get the
numbers
right. So, what we did here,
let's put
0 5,
1 1,
and -10 10 to make this easy.
So, what's the idea?
If firm one does not enter,
well, that's great for firm two, the
incumbent. They're the monopolist,
they're all by themselves, so they get a
payoff of five. Firm one isn't entering,
so they get a payoff of zero.
If firm one does enter, well, then the
payoffs to the firms depend on whether
to accommodate the entrant or fights.
If they accommodate, then they both do
pretty well, they both get one, but of
course not as well as firm two would
have gotten if firm two were by himself
as monopolist.
And then if firm two fights, that's
really bad for for both sides. They have
a price war, prices go say really low,
and and this is bad for everyone. Um you
know, we're thinking of fighting in kind
of an abstract sense. Uh it could
literally involve violence, or it could
be cutting prices, or it could be
flooding the market. There's a lot of
things it could be.
So, let's now
just write this as a this is a bit of a
review today of kind of our standard
strategic form game box. Player one has
two strategies, n e. Player two has two
strategies, a f.
I'll write this n e to keep the order
consistent.
And let's see, if player one doesn't
enter,
then they both get 0 5 either way.
If player one does enter, then the
payoffs depend on what player two does,
and we get one one here.
And negative 10.
Negative 10 here.
Well, now let's just do our standard
approach to try to find the Nash
equilibrium of this. This is a good
little review. The final exam is going
to be cumulative, so you do have to
remember
how to how to solve the basic games. So,
let's see. We go down here. If firm two
is going to accommodate, then it's
better for firm one to enter.
If firm two is going to fight,
it's better for firm one to not enter.
And then we can do things the other way.
If firm one doesn't enter, actually it
doesn't matter what firm two does.
If firm one enters, then firm two would
rather accommodate.
So, we get two equilibria.
We get EA
and NF.
Which we can see on our graph
here.
Now, both of these are Nash equilibria,
but we precisely introduce subgame
perfect Nash equilibria as a more
demanding solution concept to rule out
one of these equilibria.
So, which of these equilibria is not a
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium? Which
one did we does subgame perfection rule
out?
Yeah. The EF
because we can't really
EF, sorry. Uh
NF or EA? Sorry.
It these it's it's one of these two,
right? It's EA and NF. Yeah.
Uh maybe yeah.
NF.
NF, I agree. Okay. And and why?
Uh because if
the entrant enters, it doesn't make
sense for the incumbent to
uh fight.
Exactly right. So,
both of these are Nash equilibria.
Only EA is a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium. As you said, NF is not
subgame perfect.
And it's not subgame perfect because it
involves a threat by firm two that is
not credible.
Firm two says, "If you enter,
I'm going to fight."
But if firm one actually enters, well,
firm two is here and they look, "Well,
wait a second. If I fight, I get
negative 10.
If I accommodate, I get one. I'm much
better off accommodating."
So, it's not optimal
for firm two to actually carry out this
punishment or this threat that they that
they threatened to carry out.
Uh formally,
well,
we have to think of the definition of
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium.
In the definition, we have to look at
every subgame.
We have the full game here, but we also
have a subgame that starts here. So,
remember this is
one subgame
of the full game.
And the problem with NF
is that fighting is not an equilibrium
of this subgame. Now, maybe weird to
think of this as a subgame cuz there's
only one player moving. But remember, we
can have a game with a single player.
And an equilibrium of a single player
game just means that player is behaving
optimally, right? So, here F is not uh a
Nash equilibrium of this subgame because
F is strictly worse for player two than
A. So, this doesn't satisfy our
definition of subgame Nash uh subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium.
But let's uh maybe change the game
slightly.
So, what if we change the game and say,
"Well, actually firm one
has two different ways of entering. They
can enter the market and produce one
kind of good, or they can enter the
market and produce a slightly different
kind of good." So, we're now going to
say that firm one is choosing between
not entering
or
I'll call it E1
or E2.
These are just two different ways they
can enter and maybe use a slightly
different marketing strategy or slightly
different pricing strategy, but they're
effectively entering either way.
Uh
and now let's
write out how this looks.
So, we have firm one here.
Firm one is now choosing
enter
not enter, sorry. Not enter, E1, or E2.
Again, if they don't enter, the payoff
is 0 5.
If they enter in this way,
firm two choose to accommodate or fight.
They enter in this way, firm two choose
to accommodate or fight.
This is still firm two, firm two.
And, you know, maybe the exact pricing
strategy they use makes a bit of a
difference, but just to make things
simpler, let's say it it doesn't really
affect their payoffs whether they sell
them in one way or a different way, or
whether they use this advertising firm
or this other advertising firm. So,
let's say the payoffs down here are
going to be 1 1,
negative 10 negative 10,
1 1, negative 10 negative
So, these are different ways of
entering, but the effect in the payoffs
is actually
uh zero. This it doesn't actually change
the way the payoffs are. And we could
change these slightly if we wanted, but
it doesn't matter.
Okay? And notice the way I'm writing
this,
uh
Let me
slightly modify this.
We have to make a choice. Does firm two
observe the advertising strategy that
firm one is using? And we're going to
assume no. So, we're going to put this
in the same information set. So, as firm
two, all I see is that firm one has
entered. I don't really know under the
hood exactly what, say, production
process they're using or what what
advertising firm they have.
Okay?
Uh
And now
let's think of the strategies in this
game. It turns out the strategies in
this game are exactly the same as the
strategies over here.
Firm one is still choosing
uh oh, sorry. For firm one, it's
slightly different.
So, firm one is choosing between N,
E1, and E2.
And firm two
is still choosing
accommodate or fight. It's the same for
firm two, but it's slightly different
for firm one.
Let's try to compute the Nash Let's try
to find some the Nash equilibria.
of this game.
Any ideas what
What are some Nash equilibria
of this game? It looks really similar,
so I think it shouldn't be too hard to
figure this out.
Well, let's let's organize it by what
firm two is doing.
Let's say firm two is accommodating.
And notice firm two makes a single
choice, accommodate or fight. It's a
single choice because these two nodes
are in the same information set. So, I
can't choose to accommodate E1 and fight
against E2 because I can't distinguish
those.
So, if firm two accommodates, what does
firm one want to do?
Yeah. E1 or E2. E1 or E2 is is is going
to be good for them. They want to enter
and they're happy to do either one. So,
we're going to get E1A
and E2A are both going to be Nash
equilibria, right?
What if firm two is going to fight?
What does firm one want to do?
Yeah.
Not enter, right? So, now it looks kind
of similar to before,
but now we actually have three
equilibria. Right?
Same idea. If firm one is going to
accommodate, then
if if sorry, firm two is going to
accommodate, then firm one wants to
enter. They're happy to enter either
way. If firm two is going to fight, then
firm one uh
doesn't want to enter.
Now, I think that NF still feels
like a non-credible threat.
For exactly the same reason as before.
Firm two is fighting.
They know that by fighting they get a
payoff of negative 10. And if they
didn't fight, they would get a payoff of
one.
So, to me this feels like a non-credible
threat. But the question is is NF a
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium of this
game?
What do people think?
Well, the first question we always have
to ask ourselves about subgame perfect
Nash is first we have to identify the
subgames. Remember, maybe we're going a
little bit back before we need to maybe
review a little bit. So, if we go all
the way back, uh what are the subgames
of
this game here?
Only the entire game is a subgame
because the decision point for player
two is all a singleton node.
Exactly right. So, we can't start
a subgame here because we would break
this information set.
We can't start here because we would
break this information set. And we can't
include both of them as part of our uh
subgame because we had a rule that a
subgame has to start with a single node.
So, the only subgame of the full game is
just the full game itself.
And if there's no not if there's no
proper subgames, no subgames other than
the game itself, then subgame perfect
Nash equilibrium doesn't have any
additional bite.
Because the additional strength of
subgame perfect Nash is it says, "In
every subgame, we must be playing a Nash
equilibrium." But if there's no other
subgames, well, it doesn't have any
bite.
So, these are Nash equilibria, and all
of these
all three
are subgame perfect.
So, this seems like maybe a problem. It
shows that our notion of subgame
perfection doesn't have the bite to rule
out non-credible threats in games like
this where we have multiple nodes in the
same information set.
And we're going to introduce our notion
of perfect Bayesian equilibrium to rule
out these kinds of non-credible threats
even in situations like this.
So, let's maybe go through a more
involved example.
So, let's think of maybe we'll call this
an application game.
People have probably
applied to internships, or jobs, or
schools like this. And sometimes there's
an optional essay, or an optional
interview, or something optional. And
often people feel it's not really
optional. If I don't do it, I'm not
going to get the job, I'm not going to
get in. Well, let's try to explore that
in this game. So, uh
let's say well, it's an application
game. We have an applicant
and we could call it a firm, or a
college, or a school. Let's say school.
Let's use school just in this example.
And we have a school.
And the applicant, let's assume has
private information uh
In this example, it could be private
information about how strong of a
candidate they are, but maybe here, just
to make it a little nicer, we'll say the
applicant privately knows how excited
they are about going to this school.
Okay? So, the applicant
uh has two types. We'll call them types.
Maybe
uh
T excited or passionate. Let's say P. TP
or TN.
So, TP says I'm really passionate about
going to the school. I really or about
this the thing that the school does. I'm
going to I want to go. And TN doesn't
really uh they're not quite as excited.
They would they still want to go, but
they're not quite as excited.
Uh
And then we have the school. And uh
the school, let's just say in words,
what they do is
they want to accept
TP
but not TN.
So, there's two kinds of students, two
kinds of applicants. I'll be more
precise for what the utilities are, but
just at a high level understand if
someone's really passionate and excited
about coming, they want to accept that
that person. If they're not excited,
they don't want to accept them.
So, let's try to let's draw out a game
tree here.
So, the applicant has private
information at the beginning of the game
about whether they're excited or not
about going to the school. And the way
that we model this is we start with a
move by nature, right? We first assume
that nature makes a move and draws this
applicant's type.
And let's we need to specify some
probabilities. So, let's say that
they're passionate with probability uh
1/2
and they're not passionate with
probability 1/2, just to make the math a
little bit easier.
Okay?
So, I need a new board just to This is
going to get a little big, this game.
Let's start here. So, we start with
nature.
And nature is first going to draw
whether this person is passionate or
not.
So, we're going to have nature making
this first move.
Probability 1/2.
Probability 1/2. And this is going to be
kind of the
the passionate student.
This is going to be the not passionate
student.
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay?
And then
the student
or the applicant. I'm going to call them
the applicant, so I'll say A.
Is going to make a choice. They can
either
submit the optional essay or not, right?
They're applying to this job, this some
or this this school, there's some
optional essay. So, let's write here,
let's say
uh
they can include the essay
or not. Maybe I'll use these words.
Okay?
>> [snorts]
>> So, they're applying either way, but
they're just choosing whether to submit
the essay.
Okay?
And now we have the school
is making a choice
whether to accept or reject the
candidate.
Let's say accept.
Reject.
And let's save some space over here, AR.
Okay?
Now, we said the school
would rather accept someone
who's passionate than somebody who's
not.
And
let's say
that
a passionate candidate gives the school
a utility of three. But uh someone who's
not excited gives the school a payoff of
negative two if they accept them.
And if they don't accept them, they're
just going to pay off from zero.
So, let's go and fill that in here.
On this side of the tree, the student is
excited, they're passionate. So, if the
school accepts them, the school is going
to get a payoff of three.
And if they reject them,
the school is going to get a payoff of
zero. I'm writing a comma here cuz we're
going to fill in the the applicant's
payoffs next. Yeah? Is there a reason
why
there are no I mean, no equal to Uh yes,
I was going to fill that out, but maybe
I'll I'll uh
Let me fill out the payoffs and then
I'll do that. So, I am going to make I'm
going to fill in some information sets
next.
Uh and then if we go over here,
if we accept the not very excited
student, then we get negative two,
negative two,
and then zero, zero. Okay?
But as you pointed out, the school only
observes whether the applicant has
submitted the optional essay. They don't
directly observe whether the student is
excited or not.
So, we're going to need to define our
information sets like this.
Here.
And like this.
So, the school has two information sets.
At this information set, I know that
you've not accept not submitted the
essay, but I don't know your true uh
enthusiasm.
At this information set, I know you've
submitted the essay,
but again, I don't know your true
enthusiasm.
Uh
Now, we need to specify the student's
payoff.
And
let's start if when the student doesn't
submit the essay,
uh let's suppose that if they're
rejected, they get a payoff of zero.
Actually, let's assume that everywhere.
So, all I'd said here is whenever the
student is rejected, they get a payoff
of zero because they want to be
accepted.
Uh
Now, if they do get accepted, let's
suppose that
So, let's talk about the value of
acceptance.
Well, it's two
to the passionate student.
It's only one to the less passionate
student. And let's assume that writing
the essay is costly.
So, writing the essay also has a cost of
C.
And I'm just using C so I can vary this
over the game, but C is a known
parameter. We all know C is just like a
number like one and two, but I just want
uh to be have some flexibility over what
this is. So, let's see if we can fill
this in. So, down here, the student is
passionate and they don't submit the
essay, and then they get accepted.
Uh yeah.
Question.
I guess I guess we'll modify it, but for
the one where the student writes the
essay and the student is rejected,
wouldn't it be zero minus
Uh good, good. Uh yes, we should do
that.
Good point. Uh they still had to write
it. Yeah. So, let's Great point. Let's
do that.
Good point.
Thank you.
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay.
Thanks. So, let's have that in here. And
now we go over here. So, let's see. The
student is passionate. They don't write
the essay and then they get accepted, so
they get two for being passionate. And
that's it.
Over here, the student is passionate,
but they have to write the essay and
then they're accepted. So, we get two
minus C.
Then we go over here. The student is not
passionate. They don't write the essay
and they're accepted, so they get one.
And then over here, the student is not
passionate and they do write the essay,
so they get one minus C.
This may be
getting a little messy, but I think we
we have everything. Maybe I'll put
parentheses around these things just to
make it a little clearer.
Okay. So, here's our
our game.
Let's get back over here. Start our
analysis.
So, we're going to look at a few
different versions of the game and a few
different kinds of equilibria, but let's
first assume that
C is less than one. Okay?
So, this means even if I'm not
passionate,
if I'm going to get accepted, it's still
worth writing the essay.
Right? The benefit of being accepted uh
outweighs uh
the essay cost. [clears throat]
And let's see if we can look for an
equilibrium
where
every student applies and writes the
essay. Because I think this is often
what we see in practice, right? Even the
students who aren't that excited, they
write some essay about how excited they
are to go to the school, right?
So, let's look for an equilibrium
which both
types of students
submit the essay.
Okay?
So, formally
let's look at the student strategy.
Remember, a student strategy has to say
what the student does as a function of
their type, as a function of their
private information.
So, we have
the passionate student
and the non-passionate student, and they
both choose the essay.
Okay? It's pretty easy.
And now we have to go to the school
and see what they do.
So,
let's put ourselves in the position of
the school
and let's look at the information set
where they have received an essay.
Right? So, remember for the school,
their information sets
are essay and no essay.
So, the school needs to decide what to
do if they see that the student has
submitted an essay and what to do if
they see the student has not submitted
an essay. Right?
And
if we sort of think about our experience
with how these things work, what is a
guess about what the school's strategy
might be if we want to try to look for
this equilibrium where all the students
are writing the essay.
What's your guess about what the school
might do?
If they see that you submitted the
essay, what are they going to do?
Probably going to accept you, right?
And if they see you didn't write the
essay,
they're going to reject you. Let's see
Let's see how this works out. Okay?
So, first we need to say, well, let's
suppose they see that you've written the
essay.
What does the school believe about your
passion for the position? Do they think
you're passionate or not passionate?
What probability do they assign?
1/2 1/2, right?
So, technically we're using Bayes' rule,
but here it's pretty simple because the
prior is half half. Half the students
are passionate, half the students are
not passionate. If all the students
submit the essay, well, then the
students who submit the essay are also
half passionate, half not passionate.
Nothing has changed. Okay?
But what does the school believe if they
see that you didn't submit the essay?
I don't know. What do you think? This is
a bit trickier. Should it be half half?
Why Why should it be half half? What's
What do you think?
I I There's not one right answer to
this. So, uh I think it's unclear. But
But Amy, you said half half. Why? I'm
guessing the idea is symmetric to the
other one where everyone submits the
essay. Like, no one submits the essay.
But
Wait. Like, so if everyone submits the
essay, you assume half half. And then
there's like you have a student that you
don't receive an essay from.
Like
it would also be half half cuz basically
the way that Bayes' rule plays out,
they're all the same numbers in both
cases.
Um Okay, so let's let's maybe write out
Let's get another thought and then let's
write out Bayes' rule and see what
happens here. Were there any other any
other thoughts on on what we do here?
Yeah. I mean, just like qualitatively,
maybe you assume that there's a greater
chance that they're not passionate.
That also seems reasonable, right? I
think there's a lot of reasonable
answers to this. But let's let's see how
Bayes' rule works, right? Um
So,
to apply Bayes' rule,
Yeah, so I think we're going to have an
issue when we apply Bayes' rule, right?
So, let's let's see what happens.
So, remember, or just sort of a quick
review of Bayes' rule,
Bayes' rule allows us to calculate
conditional probabilities. So, it allows
us to say something like
if we have two events, A and B, what is
the probability that event A occurs
conditional on B occurring?
And the rule for Bayes' rule is that
this is
the probability of A and B occurring
divided by
the probability of B occurring.
And the sort of basic picture that we
give,
if this is sort of A and this is B,
well, what's the probability of A
occurring given B? Well, if we know that
B occurred, we know we're somewhere in
this circle.
The probability that A occurs given B
is saying, what's given that we're in
this circle B, what's the likelihood
that we're in the shaded region?
And that's exactly what's being pictured
here. P of A intersect B is the
probability that we're in this shaded
region and probability B is just the
probability that we're in
this outer circle. Okay?
So, let's try to apply Bayes' rule when
we see that the student writes the
essay. Right? So, what we're interested
in
is
given essay,
we want to say, what is the probability
that the student is passionate, TP,
given that they write the essay?
And Bayes' rule tells us this is equal
to the probability that they're
passionate and they write the essay
divided by the probability that they
write the essay.
Now,
the probability they write the essay is
a little hard to calculate. Let's break
it up down.
Let's So, write this one more time.
Maybe I'll write it over here to give
myself more space. This is the
probability that they're passionate
and they write the essay
divided by Well, there's two ways they
could write the essay. They could be
passionate and then write the essay, or
they could be not passionate and write
the essay. So, let me break it down like
that. We have the probability of TP and
essay
plus the probability
of TN.
Okay?
So, let's see if we can fill this in.
What is the probability that they're
passionate and they write the essay?
Well, they always write the essay.
So, this is just the probability that
they're passionate, and that's 1/2.
Right?
And on the bottom, again, we have the
1/2
plus
we're going to get a second 1/2.
Because the probability that they're not
passionate and they write the essay,
well, if they're not passionate, they
always write the essay.
So, this is just the probability that
they're not passionate, which is also
1/2.
So, we get a half divided by a half plus
a half, and that's going to be one.
Okay?
I think it's good to kind of
go over this carefully once, and then I
think people get the hang of it. Any uh
any questions on this?
Uh two questions. Okay, great. Yeah.
This is just trying to solve
This is just uh confirming this. Yeah,
yeah. Yeah. Yes.
So, then in the other case, So, let's go
Let's go to the other case. Yeah, yeah.
So, okay. Uh
So, maybe I'll erase our little review
and go to the other case.
So, now we want to say, given that we
see a student
We didn't expect to see this. We thought
everyone was supposed to write an essay.
That's what they're supposed to do under
their equilibrium strategy. But now we
see
that someone submits an application with
no essay.
And we say, well, how What belief should
we form about the student? Well, let's
apply Bayes' rule.
We say, what's the probability that
they're actually passionate, that I want
to accept them, given no essay?
And that's exactly equal to
the probability that they're passionate
and no essay
divided by the probability of no essay.
And what is this?
Yeah.
Zero over zero.
>> This is zero over zero, right?
Because I'm never No one is writing no
essay.
Don't know. Everyone is writing an
So, the probability that you're
passionate and you don't write an essay
is zero.
Because if you're passionate, you always
write an essay.
The probability that you don't submit an
essay, well, if you're passionate, you
always submit an essay. If you're not
passionate, you always submit an essay.
So, we get a zero here as well.
So, what we see is that there's a
fundamental problem with Bayes' rule,
that Bayes' rule only allows us to
define conditional probabilities
conditional on events that have positive
probability.
When we try to define conditional
probabilities conditioned on zero
probability events, Bayes' rule doesn't
really apply, and we run into problems.
So, I'll say not well defined.
And I think this is exactly why we got a
few different answers here. What should
we conclude when someone doesn't write
an essay? I think there's a few
reasonable choices, right? You might
say, well,
this isn't supposed to happen, so let me
just go back to my prior and say it's
half half.
You could say, well, the fact that they
don't want to write an essay, that must
mean they're not really passionate about
the program. I'm going to assume they're
I'm going to say that they're not
passionate. Or maybe you think they are
passionate and they just,
you know, I don't know. You could tell a
lot of stories. But basically, we don't
really pin down what the belief is.
But now this creates a problem.
Because now the question is,
So, this equilibrium seems seems to fit.
Let's see if this makes sense.
If I'm the student,
if I believe that the school is going to
accept me if I write an essay and not
accept me if I don't write the essay,
then it's optimal for me to write the
essay.
That makes sense.
And given that all the students are
writing the essay, well, the school is
happy to accept you because the school
gets a payoff of three from accepting a
passionate student, negative two from
accepting a not passionate student, and
the average of three and negative two is
strictly positive.
So, everything looks good here. The only
question is is this a credible threat?
There was a question here. Yeah. I was
just curious like if like you were to
get someone to submit an essay, could
that also imply that maybe there's a
third type of student that you don't
know about?
That's That's a good point. So, maybe
you want to re- revise your model of the
world, right? And maybe our types We've
only represented types by how excited
they are about the program, but maybe
there's like a laziness component that
we also need to need to model, right?
Or, and we'll talk about this later, it
could be that this cost C varies in the
population.
Uh again, talking about essay costs, I
feel like it's zero for everyone in the
real GPT, but in the old days, there was
a cost, and some people were better at
writing essays, and the cost for them
was lower. And we're going to talk about
that later. Yeah, exactly.
So, I guess the the basic question here
is is this a credible threat? Is it
credible for the school to say, as they
do in this equilibrium, if you don't
submit an essay, we're going to reject
you?
Yeah. Well, isn't it kind of murky
because we were just talking about there
are some ways you can get sailed if you
don't write an essay that you're not
passionate, so we don't want you. But,
what if the school has like a really
different way of thinking like, "Oh, if
you didn't write the essay, that's cuz
you were spending more time studying for
the exam, so then like we're actually
like more excited." So, I think because
you don't know exactly what the school
will conclude, the threat is like it's
not as good.
I think that's a great answer. So, it's
definitely murky, and that's exactly
what I'm trying to convey with this
example, that it is murky. But, I think
the key point, which you hinted at, was
whether this threat is credible
depends on what the school believes when
they don't see an essay.
So, is this threat credible? Well, it
depends on the belief.
If the school believes that everyone who
doesn't submit an essay is passionate,
then it's not credible for them to say
we're going to reject those students
because they rather accept passionate
students than not.
But, if their belief after not seeing an
essay is that the student is not
passionate, then it is credible for them
to reject that student because that's
exactly what's optimal for them if they
see that a student if they believe that
a student is not passionate.
So, how do we get around this? Well,
beliefs aren't well defined,
but whether something is credible
depends on the belief.
The way we get at this is our
equilibrium notion is going to need to
explicitly specify what beliefs the
school forms even at this information
set.
So, beliefs
So, as a result,
beliefs must be part of the equilibrium.
Why?
Well,
strat- Specifying strategies alone is
not enough to tell us what people
believe, but a whole equilibrium notion
is supposed to capture whether these
threats are credible, and therefore
we're going to need to explicitly
specify what the belief is.
And what we'll see here
is that here there's no flexibility in
what belief we specify here. In this
case, the belief is pinned down by
Bayes' rule. Bayes' rule tell us tells
us what the belief has to be.
Here, we have we can choose whatever
belief we want. There's no further
restriction
imposed by Bayes' rule on what the
school's belief is here.
Now, I said before there's all this big
debate in the literature about how to
define it.
People came along and made all these
arguments about what belief should be at
this kind of information set. What
should you believe here? For now, we're
not we're not going to impose any
restrictions on what those beliefs are.
And now I'm going to go into kind of the
formal
definition.
Uh
Let's go back over here.
Let's define
perfect Bayesian equilibrium.
So, the first key point is that one
thing I've harped on throughout the
semester is no longer true. So,
throughout the semester I've said an
equilibrium is a strategy profile, and I
said this over and over again.
Now, that's no longer true because an
equilibrium is going to be a strategy
profile together with beliefs. So, we're
going to have to have this new object,
which is going to be called an
assessment.
I think this is a silly word, but this
is the word that's used, and that
specifies two things.
It specifies a strategy profile,
and also beliefs, or sometimes it's
called a belief system.
So, strategy profile,
we already know what that is. It
specifies a strategy for each player,
and a strategy in this game, and in any
game, is a mapping from information sets
to actions. It's a complete contingent
plan that says at my information set at
any of my information sets, what am I
going to do?
So, in this game,
it's exactly what we wrote down over
here.
The student has two information sets, TP
and TN. So, a strategy for the student
specifies what they do at TP and what
they do at TN.
Similarly, the school has two
information sets. The information set
where they observe the student wrote an
essay, and the information set where
they observe the student didn't write an
essay, and the strategy specifies what
action they take at each of those
information sets.
So, I said that in words. Now, a belief
system
is going to specify
specifies a belief
at every
non-singleton
information set.
Okay? So, a lot of the information sets
are singletons. I don't need to specify
a belief here. I only need to specify a
belief at an information set that
contains multiple nodes.
And what is a belief? A belief is going
to be a probability distribution over
the nodes in that information set. And
that's exactly what we did here. We
said,
if the student submitted an essay,
we had two nodes in that information
set, and we had to form belief about
what was the relative likelihood of
those two nodes.
And similarly, at this information set,
no essay, or maybe I got it backwards,
at the essay information set, we have to
form a belief about the two nodes within
that information set. So, a belief at
every non-singleton information set,
what is a belief?
i.e.,
a probability distribution
over Well, it can't be over all nodes. I
certainly can't assign positive
probability to nodes that are not in
that information set. It's only a
distribution over the nodes that are
within that information set.
So, it's a probability distribution over
nodes
in the information set.
So, now we've defined an assessment.
Let's formally define a perfect Bayesian
equilibrium.
So, definition, an assessment
is a PBE
if it satisfies two conditions.
The first condition is sequential
rationality.
And the second is belief consistency.
Let's start with belief consistency.
This is what we're getting at here. We
want to say that
the school's belief here must be
half-half,
but the school's belief here is totally
flexible.
So, what belief consistency says
is, well, the beliefs are consistent.
The beliefs
are consistent with Bayes' rule.
Well,
they can't be consistent with Bayes'
rule everywhere. Sometimes we use this
vague phrase, "wherever possible."
There's often different ways of defining
exactly what wherever possible means.
What I mean by wherever possible is at
any information set that's reached with
positive probability.
So,
i.e.,
Now, let's be careful. The probability
that we reach an information set depends
on the strategy profile, right? So, what
we're saying is we have an assessment.
Looking at the strategy profile that's
part of that assessment, I can go to
every information set, and I can compute
the probability that we actually reach
that information set under the strategy
profile, and I can split those
information sets in two. I can say
there's some information sets that are
reached with positive probability, and
there's some that are never reached.
And the ones that are reached with
positive probability, the beliefs at
those information sets must satisfy
Bayes' rule.
But, at the other information sets that
are not reached with with positive
probability, I have total flexibility
over over those beliefs.
There's no restriction on the beliefs
there.
So, now sequential rationality,
we're close. Well, the whole point of
introducing beliefs
was to determine whether these threats
were credible.
And what credible meant precisely was
optimal, right? Optimal given my beliefs
and given the strategy of others. So,
sequential rationality means
at every information set
the action under the strategy profile
is optimal
given beliefs
and the rest of the strategy profile.
And
I would say the rest.
This kind of a quote.
So, what do I mean here?
Whenever we get to an information set
a strategy is going to specify what
action the player is supposed to take
at that information set.
And that action that they're supposed to
take better be optimal.
Well, how do we define that it's
optimal? We have to check
that it's optimal given the beliefs that
the player has there
and how everyone else is going to play
which is the rest of the strategy
profile.
So, what's optimal for me at this node
depends on or at this information set
depends on my beliefs over which node
I'm actually at and also how people are
going to subsequently play in the game.
And the way they subsequently play is
pinned down by the rest of the strategy
profile.
I could write all this in math and
that's what the notes do, but I think
that maybe just makes things a little
more confusing. So, I'm trying to write
in words, but if anything's unclear
Uh so, let's go back to this game and
see if we can
find some some more
uh
PBE.
So
just look here.
So, let's try to finish off our our
construction of a perfect Bayesian
equilibrium over here.
We already have a strategy for for the
student. We already have a strategy for
the school.
The next step is you have to specify
beliefs.
We've already specified the half half
belief.
But, we have flexibility over the P 1
minus P belief.
So, let's emphasize here that this is
unconstrained by Bayes' rule.
Now, one confusion I've often see on
problem sets or exams is people say,
"Oh, here's my equilibrium. You can take
P whatever you want."
Just because it's unconstrained by
Bayes' rule to write down an
equilibrium, we still have to make a
choice about what this is. We have a lot
of flexibility in what that choice is,
but you still have to make a concrete
choice. You can't say the equilibrium is
whatever P you want. You have to choose
a particular P
um and that's what we're going to do
here. So, let's see what P we can
choose.
So, this P is unconstrained by Bayes'
rule
but it is constrained by something else.
It is constrained by sequential
rationality.
Say SR. Why?
Why am I not allowed to choose whatever
P I want here? To make this So, I want
to make this
construct here a perfect Bayesian
equilibrium.
But, you might think, "Oh, I can just
choose whatever P I want." But, I think
there's an there's an issue. Yeah?
I mean, if you were to accept like or to
assume that was more
um
passionate than non-passionate, right?
Then what you suggest is
rejecting
like would have been a higher utility
Exactly right. So, let's check whether
rejecting is sequentially rational given
this belief.
Okay? So, my payoff as the school is
always zero if I reject, right?
So, my payoff from rejecting
is zero.
What's my expected payoff from accepting
given this belief, right? My expected
payoff from accepting depends on the
belief, right? So, let's write it down,
yeah? So, we have Well, P is the
probability that the student is
passionate. And if they're passionate, I
think we said I get a payoff of
three, right?
And if they're not passionate
I get a payoff of -2.
So, in order for rejecting to be
sequentially rational at this node, it
must be that the expected payoff from
rejecting is weakly higher than the
expected payoff from accepting.
So, I need zero to be greater than equal
to this.
Right?
And now let's simplify this a little
bit.
Uh we get
3P and then we get
5P
-2.
That's right.
So, we need zero greater than equal to
5P -2. Let's put the two over here and
then divide by five.
So, we must get P
less than or equal to 2/5.
So, we've actually constructed a family
of perfect Bayesian equilibria. For any
P that you give me, as long as that P is
smaller than 2/5, we have a perfect
Bayesian equilibria where the student
always submits the essay, the school
accepts if you submit an essay, they
reject if you don't submit an essay, and
if they see that you don't submit an
essay, they assign belief P to you being
a passionate student.
And that belief P must be small enough
that it's credible uh for them to
actually reject. Yes. So, does that mean
that given different students, as long
as like they can assign one person 3 and
one person like I like any like
different students who don't submit
essays can have different values of P as
long as P is less
Uh so, I think you're describing a
slightly different game. So, here
yeah, here we've kind of made a
simplification here where we've
basically imagined that there's really
only one student.
So, you know, here what we're imagining
is a student is drawn from the
population and uh applies.
Uh I think this is a reasonable model if
in reality what happens is many people
apply, but the school adopts a uniform
rule. They either uh accept students
with essays or they don't uh and they
either accept students who don't have
essays or they don't. Uh if they wanted
to do something more complicated where
there's five applications and they do
different things to different
applications, then we'd have to
explicitly model the number of
applications and you know, here look at
the information set. All I see is I see
one applicant and it's either an essay
or not an essay. And if we want to
capture what you're describing, which I
think is important for applications, we
need to enrich the the game.
We're just looking at one student uh or
the interpretation is kind of a uniform
policy that treats all students equally.
If you wanted to treat students
differently, then we'd have to enrich
the game.
Um
Great. So, this is what's called a uh
Let's put it this in words. This is
what's called a pooling equilibrium.
It's called a pooling equilibrium
because both types of students, the
passionate and the non-passionate
students, choose the same action.
They pool together and all submit
essays. And as a result, their choice
about whether to submit an essay doesn't
reveal that much information about
whether they're passionate or not.
So, next let's see if we can compute a
what's called a separating equilibrium
where different types of students uh
make different choices.
Let's go up here.
Last thing we do.
So, earlier I'd assumed that C, remember
C is the cost of submitting an essay,
was less than one. Let's now relax that
assumption and let's let C be arbitrary.
So
let C be arbitrary.
And now what we'd like to do is see for
which values of C
can we find a separating equilibrium?
Okay? And this is actually kind of exam
question I often uh I like to ask where
we you try to find the set of parameter
values such that something is an
equilibrium.
So, let's see if we can work through
this. So
we want to look for an equilibrium
where the essay distinguishes the types
of students. I think this is exactly why
schools offer optional essays. What
they're hoping is the people who really
want to get in and are excited write the
essay and the people who don't really
want to get in don't write the essay. I
think it often doesn't work cuz we end
up in the other equilibrium I described
where everyone submits the essay even if
they don't want to go, but this is the
idea and if essays are costly enough,
this is what what might work.
So, we're looking for an equilibrium
where what is the student doing?
Well
if they're passionate
they submit the essay.
And if they're not passionate
they don't submit the essay.
And then what does the school do?
Well
let's first specify the school's
beliefs. Okay?
In this case, both information sets are
reached with positive probability.
There's a positive probability that a
student submits an essay and a positive
probability that a student does not
submit an essay. So, in this case we can
apply Bayes' rule at both information
sets. We don't run into this issue of
dividing by zero and these beliefs are
going to be well defined.
So, if I see that a student submits an
essay,
given that this is the strategy, what
does Bayes' rule tell me as a school?
What is the probability that they're
passionate, and what is the probability
that they're not passionate?
Yeah, it's just one, and I think the way
I'm writing it, let's write this 1 0.
So, I say there's a probability one that
they're passionate and zero that they're
not passionate.
What if I see that there's no essay?
Well, now it's the opposite. The only
students who don't submit essays are the
ones who are not passionate. So, I'm
certain that they must be not
passionate,
and I get 0 1.
Okay?
Well, now it's pretty clear.
If I'm certain that students who submit
the essay are passionate, I certainly
want to accept them.
And if I'm certain that students who
don't submit the essay are not
passionate, then I certainly want to
reject them.
Okay?
So, here's our candidate equilibrium,
and let's just sort of go through the
conditions.
And I think this is always a good way to
check.
So, does this equilibrium satisfy belief
consistency? Yes, right? We just checked
Bayes' rule, so we're good here.
Just a reminder, when I say equilibrium,
notice I've not just specified the
strategies, I've also specified the
beliefs.
And that's because this is an
assessment, not just a strategy profile,
right?
Okay, so I have belief consistency. Now
I move to sequential rationality. Well,
let me separately check it for the
student and the school.
Sequential rationality for the school is
pretty clear, right? This is what I
already said. They're accepting students
who they think are likely to be
passionate, and they're rejecting
students they think are likely to be un-
not passionate.
So, we're good here.
But what about sequential rationality
for the student? This is going to be a
little trickier, and this is going to
depend on C, yeah?
Yeah, I was going to say, does the
expected value for
a non-passionate student have to be
like negative for not writing it?
Right, so let's exactly check it out.
So, there's two things we have to check.
We have to check that if I'm a
passionate student, I prefer writing an
essay to not.
And if I'm a not passionate student, I
prefer not writing an essay to writing
an essay, right? So, let's just write
that down in math, uh but in words,
that's exactly what we want.
So, let's suppose I'm a student who's
passionate.
Okay?
And
if I write an essay, what is my payoff?
And if I don't write an essay, what is
my payoff?
Well, if I'm passionate and I write an
essay,
what happens? What's my payoff here?
2 - C, right?
Okay?
And if I don't write an essay, well, I'm
not accepted,
and I don't write the essay, so my
payoff is just zero, right?
Now, notice a really crucial point here.
The school's strategy
is that if you don't submit an essay,
you're rejected.
When I as a passionate student
contemplate deviating and not submitting
an essay,
when I don't submit an essay, the
school's strategy is fixed, and
therefore they reject me.
People have to get confused here cuz you
might say, "Well, the school's belief is
wrong. Their belief is that only
non-passionate students
don't submit essays."
And now a passionate student is
submitting an essay.
But the school can't tell the
difference. If the the school's belief
is that if you don't submit an essay,
you can't be passionate. And if if a
passionate student deviates and doesn't
send an essay, they're not able to
change the beliefs that the school has.
The belief has the school has their
beliefs fixed, and therefore what
happens to them when they don't write an
essay is determined by the strategy of
the school. It doesn't change. Some
people are tempted to say, "Oh, they're
passionate, so now the school's going to
accept them." No. It's a unilateral
deviation, the school's strategy is
fixed, and we're considering what
happens when a passionate student
deviates by not submitting this.
Okay, now let's consider a
non-passionate student.
They're not submitting an essay,
and again, they're getting a payoff of
zero.
What if they submitted an essay?
What would their payoff be?
Yeah. 1 - C. 1 - C.
Again,
they're able to trick the school. If
they submit the essay, they successfully
trick the school, and the school's going
to accept them, even though the school
doesn't want to accept non-passionate
people, but they have to pay the essay
cost of C.
So, now let's check the equilibrium
conditions.
A passionate student is supposed to
submit the essay,
so we need 2 - C
to be greater than or equal to zero.
But a non-passionate student is not
supposed to submit the essay, so uh we
need zero greater than or equal to 1 -
C.
So,
what's our solution?
Well, this is going to be an equilibrium
if both of these inequalities are
satisfied,
and that's going to be true if 1 is less
than or equal to C
less than or equal to 2.
And let's try to understand the role of
this. Why do we have these two
assumptions?
Well, we want the essay to separate the
good students from the bad students.
If C what would go wrong if C was too
big? If C was greater than 2?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's so costly. If you say you
have to write 100 essays, well, no one's
going to apply to your school, again, in
the pre-GPT world.
So, we're not able to separate the
students, right?
If C is too low, what goes wrong? If C
is less than 1, well, even the
non-passionate students say, "Well, it's
a one-paragraph essay, I can do that."
It's worth it for me to do that.
So, if you think of the school as kind
of, you know, this is a broader question
about the game, you could think of the
design question, if the school can
choose C by choosing how hard the essay
is, they might want to choose the essay
to be kind of a moderate difficulty.
It's hard enough to deter the the
uninspired students from applying, but
easy enough that the that the inspired
students will still apply. And I think
that's exactly what admissions offices
uh and and jobs think
Okay, let me uh stop there, unless
there's any questions.
And I'll see everyone next week.